hello everyone so this is the second in
our very unusual two-part series here on
space time
our great quest to understand the
universe to find the mechanics of base
reality
and to understand why our universe
exists at all seem to be at
an impasse for the past century after
the great revolutions of relativity
and quantum mechanics so together with
professor brian keating astrophysicist
and friend
we're joining forces to bring together
some of the leading researchers
uh in particle physics and in cosmology
to look for a way forward brian great to
have you on space time again
it's wonderful to be back with you and
all of our esteemed guests it's a real
treat and thrill for me
last time we had an amazing uh line up
uh we had max tegmark we had james beach
and stefan alexander and i think we
really
you know started to converge on on some
some useful thoughts uh i really
encourage you to
go back and watch that it's only 90
minutes long as we'll be today's
but today our luminaries are no less
luminous um and i'm just going to give
you
a few words on on each of the people we
have here today
my my pleasure introduce eric weinstein
who
is a very unique case uh holding a phd
in mathematical physics from harvard but
did not pursue the traditional academic
route at all
he's an author a mathematician and
economist and managing director
of teal capital and eric practices
physics
outside the academic establishment in
that regard is most famous for his
geometric unity proposal
uh and you can go to his podcast
the portal and to the portal wiki
for the details on this radical new idea
and the links to that will be in the
description sabina hossenfelder
uh there's a theoretical physicist at
the frankfurt institute of advanced
studies um
where she works extremely broadly uh but
generally in quantum gravity research
uh sabine is also a prolific writer for
popular media a blogger and a youtuber
sabina uh i really want to thank you
for your incredible youtube channel uh
these wonderful physics videos really
i've learned more on your videos than
turning anywhere else on youtube and
possibly most of the internet welcome
finally lisa mullen joins us lee has
been a central figure in our quest for
the deepest laws of the universe for
decades and has worked in many and
perhaps all of the ideas that we will
discuss today
from loop quantum gravity which is one
of the founders to string theory to the
foundations of quantum mechanics and the
philosophy of
physics uh and lee is a founding member
of the perimeter institute
and is the author author of many books
actually
including quite appropriate to today the
trouble with physics
the rise of string theory the fall of
science and what comes next
also time reborn from the crisis in
physics to the future of the universe
which
i have a very dog-eared copy right here
it's um
my favorite beach reading and more
recently einstein's unfinished
revolution the search for what lies
beyond the quantum
lee it's an honor to have you on board
it's a pleasure to be here thank you
very much
i was wondering uh lee would you be able
to
just give us a quick overview of what we
mean by
when we when we talk about a quest for a
theory of everything yes
well it means the theory of everything
is
means different things to different of
us and we should make that clear
to many people it means a unified theory
of the elementary particles and the
interactions
and that's a hope which has been ongoing
for a long time
and there has been we'll discuss some
interesting ideas but
very little progress another thing you
might mean by a theory of everything
is the unification of
the theory of gravity with quantum
theory and with quantum field theory and
the rest of the elementary particles
and that's the aspect of the problem
that i've mostly worked on
the question of how to fit together our
understanding of gravity
space and time and cosmology
probably given to us by general
relativity with quantum physics
there's a third thing you might mean by
a theory of everything
which is the completion of quantum
theory because there are a number of
people who are of the view
that quantum theory is incomplete and
that the issues
needed to complete quantum theory are
the reasons for the slow
progress in the other
ways of going at a quote theory of
everything
and my own personal view which i suspect
will
actually will not be agreed to by
my friends here is that the fundamental
troubles are having to do with
foundations of quantum mechanics with
the notion of
space of locality and
that the overall set of problems
stemming from cosmology the initial
conditions the why this universe
why these elementary particles and their
forces
have ultimately to do also with issues
that
will be needed to understand how quantum
mechanics really makes sense
and the last thing i'll say is that i
think everybody's asking the wrong
question
i think people who are still wondering
at why the elementary participant forces
have the structure
that they do the particular symmetries
the particular arrangements of particles
are like biologists before darwin trying
to understand the a priori reasons why
there are snails and cats and dogs
without the key idea and the key idea is
evolution
and i think that the the question we
should be asking
is how do the laws evolve under watch
the dynamics
and why do we have why did the universe
choose the laws that we have this
particular mix of elementary particles
and their forces
and that the progress will come to
focusing on the mechanisms by which laws
evolve
rather than the particular
so that's my provocation to my cancer
we feel provoked that that's uh
fascinating yes it's also
echoes a little bit uh of i think where
we got to the end
of the last um session
and max tegmark echoed similar views
about you know
looking to this this hole in the
foundations of quantum theory
uh but before we get into those uh
details
perhaps uh sabine would you mind giving
us a similar
state of the field address okay um
yeah so as we already said different
people mean different things
by theory of everything uh some of which
i think
are better motivated as a target of our
investigations and others not as well
motivated
as james said the last time we have this
issue that the standard model of
particle physics doesn't want to
cooperate with gravity
so we're in this peculiar situation
where we have two theories
uh that each individually work perfectly
fine but if you try to
use them together on the same situation
uh
then it just doesn't work uh and it's
not like the situation just does not
exist
do not exist in the universe um they
they do very well exist for example in
the very early universe towards the big
bang or in the center of
black holes but also in principle
every time we bring a particle into a
superposition of two locations
then we don't know what happens with the
gravitational field
and that's because we have not been able
to combine
properly quantum theory um with
gravity um so that's just an
inconsistency and that's something that
the theory of everything
um should be able to do you know just to
tell us what what
happens in these circumstances um but
then other people want the theory of
everything to do more
um for example they they wanted to
explain why
the particles in the senate model have
this particular structure what do they
come in three generations why are the
gauge groups these particular gauge
groups
and it would also be nice um if these
gauge groups would not just be
sitting next to each other like we have
these three different types of
symmetries in the standard model
but if they were combined to one large
asymmetry
and this is normally called uh grant
unification or a grand
unified theory and so
a theory of everything for many people
especially for string theorists
should combine both this grand
unification
with quantum gravity
and uh so it's no secret uh what i
personally think of this
this i this necessity that we
uh we have to remove the inconsistency
between quantum theory and gravity
is the real one so we know that uh this
this just cannot be how nature works
right nature doesn't doesn't have any
consistency there has to be an answer to
that question
what happens with the gravitational
field of a particle and a superposition
but when it comes to the structure of
the particles in the standard model
then uh yeah i mean that's maybe you may
say well that's not
pretty the way that it is and i would
say uh well who cares what you think is
pretty
the standard model works just perfectly
fine
so to me uh banging on this question uh
i'm very sympathetic to what we said um
banging on this question like why do the
particles fall into this particular
pattern
it's just not particularly constructive
it's not something that will
move us forward i can say a little more
about approaches to quantum gravity if
someone's interested in that well i
would say we're all very
much interested in that and actually
that this is a good idea uh
just starting out still setting our you
know our stage
um let's do perhaps a quick survey i
i don't know if you want to take up take
some of those sabine and maybe
you can take some yeah it won't take
long so
um one of the approaches to quantum
gravity is loop quantum gravity and i
think i'll let le
say something about this then i already
mentioned
uh string theory this this is probably
the best known approach
uh to quantum gravity which is um which
principle also uh contains a grant
unification
so the idea of string theory is that
everything is made of strings
uh so that it sounds pretty lame but it
turns out that if you try to
formulate it mathematically it's a
highly restrictive framework
and out comes an interaction that looks
like
gravity so a string theory when
quantized gives you a theory of
gravity and when people realize this uh
in in the late 70s early 80s everyone
was very excited about it because it
looked like they had stumbled
upon the theory of everything um and
then there are several other approaches
to quantum gravity in particular
which focus on resolving this this
inconsistency
between quantum theory and gravity for
example there's causal dynamical
triangulation
that's basically an attempt to
discretize
space uh and then take a continuum limit
and that's based on a path integral
approach um
this idea of feinman
there is an idea which is called
asymptotically safe gravity that
originally goes back to
an idea by stephen weinberg
which says that actually we can quantize
gravity
the same way that we quantize the other
interactions and um
it's just that if we do it naively and
don't think about what the result is
then it looks like that
theory is sick but if you look at it um
a little more closely and think about it
and then the theory is actually actually
fine it's asymptotically
safe and so the interesting thing about
asymptotically safe gravity um is that
where for one to my knowledge it's the
only approach that
correctly predicted the value of the
higgs mars
and i think that's that's an
unappreciated success
uh of this um of this idea
but it also in principle contains uh or
it's able to contain a grand unified
theory um
so asymptotically safe gravity is
a contender for a theory of everything
um it's it's somewhat of a mystery to me
why it doesn't get
more attention and then maybe finally
let me
add emergent gravity because this came
up in the discussion
last week and this is the approach that
among other people
is being pursued by eric verlinde so the
idea of
emergent gravity is to say that
the attempt of taking general relativity
and trying to quantize it
to get a theory of gravity is as
ill-conceived as the idea of taking say
water and quantizing it to get a theory
of atoms
it just it doesn't get you what what you
want namely a more fundamental
um theory so um in in this idea
gravity is really an emergent force that
comes from the interaction of
many many tiny constituents which are
sometimes
called the atoms of space-time but um
you know you shouldn't take this too
seriously
in any case the idea is that gravity
comes from this
interaction of many microscopic
constitutions and
the big question is what are these
microscopic constituents
it's eric's still there why don't you
let eric say something
eric please uh if you don't mind well
so this is the embarrassing part because
i'm not a physicist i'm also not
cowed by uh by where we are in physics i
have a somewhat different impression
which is that we haven't really seen
theories of everything
and so we haven't thought enough about
what the really difficult conceptual
problems are
and i've analogized it to escher's
drawing hands how do you create
a a background
in the form of a piece of paper and when
the paper generates ink and the ink
generates pictures of hands which
draw each other you know like you're
bootstrapping reality into existence
so there are conceptual problems with
theories of everything
that we've been avoiding in the same way
that if you're going on a
a uh a jabberwock hunt and you've never
met a jabberwock you have no idea what
it is
um you're bravely going off with your
shovel and your bb gun and your compass
but you have no idea what it is that
you're actually trying to track
and i think that where we are is very
interesting and exciting which is that
up until
you know 50 years ago we were going
great guns
and then everything suddenly came to a
halt we just didn't think a lot about
the way in which we had an old project
called unified field theory
and then somehow it got changed
to quantum quantum gravity that if we
could only quantize gravity
that would be the holy grail and i think
that was an amazing piece of sleight of
hand
um because these were different these
were different views a unified field
theory is much closer to what
we've been describing as grand unified
theories which take three out of four
forces
and of course we name it some bizarre
thing like grand unification because
it's less grand than actual unification
just to confuse people
but you know in large measure we've had
unifications maxwell's unification
of all electromagnetic phenomena
is probably the greatest one what's
happened in the last 50 years is that
we've had a complete stall out in terms
of the ability of theoretical physics to
predict what comes
next tell us what to do to find really
new stuff
and as a non-physicist i can tell you
that
from outside it looks like the political
economy of physics
is destroying the actual research
potential so that's what's fascinating
to me
and i'm really looking forward to doing
as much battle
as our internet connections uh will
allow with sabine
my friend and colleague because i think
she's a great curmudgeon
who refuses to get swept up in the
nonsense
and i do think that there is a case uh
to be made for
looking at the nonsense around string
theory around quantum gravity
and the sleight of hand by which we had
one set of dreams replaced by another
and somehow bizarrely nobody noticed the
unified field theory concept
melted away and it became the imperative
to quantize gravity not
only to possibly reverse it and the idea
is maybe we should geometrize the
quantum because
gravity has always been geometric that's
really what the big story of the last
50 years has been is the geometrization
of the quantum
but because the propaganda in physics is
so oppressive
we don't even get to tell what we
actually did do and we're stuck with the
story pretending that we did something
with it which we didn't do which was
quantum gravity
and what we did do was grab geometrize
the quantum which is
um both with something called geometric
quantization
principally in the 70s and also
geometric
and topological and conformal quantum
field theories which are that's the big
story of now
we failed in physics but we super
succeeded
at figuring out why the edifice of
quantum field theory is a coherent whole
rather than a grab bag of techniques
that somehow just barely managed to work
sabine maybe you could respond directly
this i think this is what
i think this is what a lot of people
came for so um i think eric is right
that
in the foundations of physics there has
been too much attention on
uh very few isolated problems that
in the end didn't lead us anywhere there
have been too many people
all banging the same drum
and now the problem is that they are
refusing to accept that it didn't go
anywhere
and what we could really need is a
larger diversity of approaches
for example like eric's maybe which
in all honesty i don't understand a
great uh deal about
but we could certainly need some
fresh input there my issue is
that i think physicists have not
paid enough attention to the question
exactly what has gone wrong it's like
all these ideas
that they have tried with grant
unification and strict theory and
supersymmetry
and some other things and you know
attempts to quantize um general
relativity that in the end didn't
uh go anywhere they haven't really
looked at just
why these approaches fade so i think
there's some self-reflection that is
missing in this community
uh when you say that these approaches
have failed and perhaps i'm thinking of
string theory in particular
you know string theory predicts this
vast mathematical structure that may or
may not describe
what the universe is but where it's
failed is to produce testable
predictions
but does that mean it's wrong or does it
just mean
we've run out of
humanly accessible space
for those testable predictions and we're
at the point where we are
uh exploring the untestable i think we
should be bolder and we should say that
the strange theory program has failed
right and the way that we should say
that is they told us what they were
going to do
and they told us what the time frame
that they were going to do it in would
be
and those things didn't happen now you
can always add epicycles effectively
and they've added a tremendous number of
epicycles so
to the the issue of whether anything is
salvageable is completely different
uh when you say they what are you who
are you referring to
so the problem crops up is that you had
an
uh and then you had a pre-history of
string theory before 1984
maybe where it was used for strong
interactions then it has a resurgence in
1984 with the anomaly
cancellation and at that point something
really dangerous happens within the
physics community which is is that the
physics community
piles into string theory with the other
things that we've tried
not working particularly well and so
there's a claim which is that everybody
believed and it's not true there were
tons of critics
including people like feynman and
glashow in 1984.
string theory was always playing by its
own rules it told us told us what it was
going to do
it told us about how long it would take
for it to do it it said that there were
only
a finite number of theories to
investigate
this is before they kept changing things
simply put
string theory in the string theorists
told us after 1984 what they would do
and then they kept changing what it was
that they were saying right so that
it went from being string theory where
it was only about strings because they
had reasons why
higher dimensional objects didn't exist
to brain theory it went from a finite
number of theories to a continuum with
those as its extreme points
as the field learned more about what it
was saying
it kept changing what it said it was
going to do so we've had
multiple iterations as string theory
figures out
that it isn't it hasn't been capable of
making the strong declarative statements
that it's made at every junction
juncture so in the issue is
that there is the corpus of string
theory that is what is
has been mathematically learned and
they've found mathematical structures
but to claim that those mathematical
structures
are the structures of the world um
is a a statement where
i would have to say the community has
failed because it told us what it was
going to do and then it repeatedly
failed to do what it said it was going
to do
that isn't to say that they might not
pivot and find something new to do
and i welcome that but yes it has failed
multiple times eric can i just address
that because
in experimental physics it's not
uncommon to have
rather extreme budget overruns i don't
know anything about this but i hear that
from experimentalists and
building ambitious projects uh that
you're always optimistic
in the beginning so i think treating it
as if it's a contract or a pledge or a
swear
you know i think that's uh you know not
fair to to what the ultimate goal is the
goal is
is to accomplish a certain product
delivery not to
do it you know explicitly in a given
time frame i think
that's standard let's agree the issue is
is that the community said we are the
only ones with the ball
we have the ball all eyes on us we will
do this
everyone else doesn't count and so my
point
is no that's not how science works you
guys made a call which is that you were
the sole
um standard bearers for physics and you
were wrong
and you need to pay that price before we
continue the conversation
with respect to that certainly
yes i would i would i would put it the
following way
quoting dick feynman this is from a
conversation with him
in the late 70s he said if there's a
question and lots of smart people have
tried to answer a question
and failed then maybe it's smart
to think that they're asking the wrong
question and to try to ask a different
question
i my sense is that
and i don't know if my friends here will
agree is that almost
nobody is working on the uh
the questions that were
driving those of us in the early 80s and
late 70s to get involved in things like
brand unification and string theory
which is to understand if there's a
structure to the elementary particles
that can be
comprehended there are a few people eric
is one of them
there's cole fury who has some very
interesting ideas having to do with
actonians
there's a handful of other people
and the situation is not very hospitable
if cole and some other people who work
on these ideas about octonion structures
have a hard time getting on the archive
which is embarrassing
[Music]
and meanwhile
um there's there's a vibrant community
doing some
interesting things but there is i'm just
including myself here
there is almost nobody working on the
original problems that
motivated people to seek
grant unification or unification of
particle physics and gravity
and subpoena you've you know recently in
your video where you kind of
call out these new theories of
everything which are in the zeitgeist as
you might say
uh and and the question of why are these
new theories like wolframs
like eric's like garrett leases uh like
holmes
like uh why are they proliferating and
you make a statement in the video and
then the nautilus piece based on it
and say that the whole idea of a theory
of everything is based on an
unscientific premise some people would
like the laws of nature to be pretty in
a very specific way
and i want to do a ganking experiment as
you might say if you permit my
crappy german and and just and just take
us back
you know to 1959 and then
ask were people guided to seek electro
week unification
you know prior to its creation they
weren't saying
here's something that would be beautiful
if we could find it let's throw
everything
into the stewpot and see what comes out
and then
if it looks pretty uh then we will
accept it i've never done science like
that i'm not a theorist but
i doubt that theorists do that it's more
that in retrospect
something might appear beautiful um but
i don't think that's ever the flight
plan
you know we never set off and say hmm i
want to go all the way
to the north pole so let me start by
going you know to 89.9 degrees
because i know it's very close and very
symmetric so
anyway it's a long question but um is
that the way that
you think theorists are actually
operating that we're
using beauty as a as a flight plan as a
roadmap
i think that that's how the
methodology in the community has
developed yes and i'm not just saying
that
because that's my personal opinion but
because i talk to people about this
um this is what my book is all about
i've literally been traveling around and
asked people
um you know what they think about beauty
as a guide to the development
of theories and the foundations of
physics and it become very very clear
that they pay a lot of attention to it
and you don't have to look for um you
know on the internet to find example of
this where people go on
on on about about how string theory can
possibly be wrong because it's so pretty
uh or the same thing with uh with
supersymmetry and so on and so forth and
i just think that's
that's an unscientific argument and i
think it's terribly embarrassing if uh
scientists
go go on and make claims like this
now as i said earlier one has to be
careful when one talks about
these approaches to a theory of
everything there are two different sets
of question here the one is a good
question
um which is how do we resolve the
inconsistency
between quantum theory and gravity
that's a
that's a hard problem it's a it's a
well-defined problem there has to be a
solution
to that now and as lee said
um that that was one of the starting
points that
got people excited about a string theory
but
uh nowadays there are few people are
actually even still working on
even solving that problem what most of
them do
is they deal with the thingery and
anti-duster space
and for all we know our universe is not
an anti-deceptive space
and if you ask them like um well why why
do you deal with anti-static space and
um don't think about uh how to
actually quantize gravity in our
universe
they're like because we know how to deal
with antidesign space
so it's like the stereotypical example
of the
person who's looking for the keys under
the lamppost because that's how they
know to solve the equations
the the other part of the question is
the one that i think is
is not a good scientific question which
is uh how how do we make the standard
model prettier by combining um these
uh symmetry groups and so on i just i
just don't think that that question will
ever
lead us anywhere but let me say
something else about this example that
you mentioned with the electroweak
unification the problem
uh with the theory before the
electroweak
unification was also a problem of
inconsistency because without this
unification the theory is not
renormalizable it's basically the same
problem that we have these days
uh with the quantization of gravity um
and so this was a good problem which
required a solution and people found the
solution and it led to a huge amount of
progress
so maybe i cannot that actually the
problem is
quite similar in in the sense that they
um
in both cases the theory um was
non-reanimalizable but the solution that
people used for the electroweak
interaction was to
realize that since it's a short-range
interaction
um you can solve the problem by
introducing a massive gauge boson so
that this solution does not work
for gravity because we know
just observationally that um the
gauge particle if you want to call it
that
for gravity is to good precision
massless so
it's kind of a similar problem but the
same solution will not also work for
gravity
so eric and lee um you both have
quite provocative perspectives on the
scientific method as a whole
eric i want to start with you and then i
want to go to lee so eric
um in the context of of the scientific
method one thing that frustrated many of
our listeners last time
was that we were basically saying things
about you know apple pie
and hot dogs or whatever you want to eat
every everybody can agree on yes we need
more experiments maybe we don't agree on
on how much those experiments would cost
but i do think that you know there's
kind of a lot of blandishments
that yeah would be great to have more
data coming in but um
but you know that kind of does feed into
this notion that there is this poparian
sense of what constitutes doing actual
science
and if it's true that we can't falsify
something
presently or in our estimation maybe
ever
that that is not worth pursuing and i
wonder what's your take eric
um you know how overarching we have
become
as physicists with pearl popper and this
victim of falsifiability
well i mean this is a very difficult
problem in part because you had
a very bad recent history with one
subset of the community
totally abusing ideas like beauty
and so sabine is in fact correct about
the abuse of beauty as a cover story for
why you're not shipping product
um but she's in fact incorrect about
beauty at a far deeper level which is um
where she and i hopefully can can find
room to disagree
which is this is an extremely dangerous
part of the real scientific method the
real scientific method is everything
that has ever worked
to get us reliable knowledge not just
the uh fairy tale that we tell people
that if they brush their teeth and
remember the floss that they'll
be invited to stockholm and you know
this idea that
we should come up with the hypoth
hypothetical deductive method we should
come up with
ideas then we should challenge them in
the laboratory and we should retool
life's a lot weirder than that and the
key problem with beauty is
that it's it's a little bit like the
blackbird the fastest airplane ever
almost nobody could fly it um well
same thing with beauty almost nobody can
get any water out of that well
but the tiny number of people who were
able to get water out of that well
i would say the three most important
people in my estimation
of the 20th century would be einstein to
rock and yang
uh even over weinberg um
those are the people whose equations
that we all use and they're
all on record as talking about beauty as
a god
and so you have this problem that it's
an extremely elitist and therefore a
very unpopular thing to say which is
now the blackbird is an amazing plane
the only three guys who can fly it
while beauty is absolutely an amazing
way to do physics and there have only
been a tiny number of people have been
able to get it to work
so the modal person sabine is absolutely
right that person is probably lying
about their prospects for success
that person is probably going to crash
and burn so let us agree that in the
hands of the modal physicist
uh beauty is a terrible guide that is
not the argument
for beauty we're all we're all super
model we're you know there's no average
physicist right so
it has your hand up and then i want to
get to leave but sabine you had a quick
response
let him finish let him finish she's
giving me enough rope to hang myself as
you can tell
um you know with respect to uh
what the real scientific method is is
you know to be blunt about it
renormalization
theory scale theories of scale have been
incredibly innervating because the
physicists have an idea of here's the
gauntlet that any theory will have to
run
at the end and the people who know that
gauntlet
find very different things beautiful
because it's anything that is a
candidate
in general too many of us outside of
that quantum field theory community
don't appreciate the dangers and
difficulties and the pitfalls that are
besetting us on all sides uh
unfortunately that community also
is incredibly innervated from guessing
which is the reason that nobody works on
reality anymore
uh for the most part and has to do with
the fact that nobody has an idea
of how to function in a straight jacket
quite this tight
and not be happy to hear with other
people so you look at sabina you look
in your article recently in nautilus
magazine and do we need a theory of
everything
and you say you know what do i think
about leases and einsteins and wolframs
in terms of the theory
well if scientific history teaches
anything their method of guessing some
pretty piece of math
and hoping it's useful for something is
extremely unpromising
we uh sabina aren't you accusing eric of
the very thing that he's saying is
problematic
um well eric's only one person so
basically he can't as one person and
he's saying problems
let me maybe uh comment directly on what
eric was just saying because it's
something that i constantly get to hear
usually from
from physicists and not from
mathematicians but it's this argument
look at these great people like einstein
uh derock
weinberg who've been talking about
beauty it worked for them
okay so why is that a bad argument
because it's cherry picking data
okay so you also have to take into
account all the people who've been
talking about
beauty for whom it did not work and
there
are lots of examples of this uh in the
history if you look at people like
uh heisenberg um eddington
uh or or even earlier you know this this
whole story with
with vortex theory and um the platonic
solids and so on so
so you have you have all these people in
the history of science who've been going
on
and on about beauty and maybe you would
say from today's perspective
these ideas were not all that beautiful
but but that's because
uh you know you have this hindsight
inside that where the ideas didn't work
the point is that at the time when they
were making
their conjectures uh their sense of
beauty
was not working and you can also just
uh see this you know basically happening
right now
people have been using this very
specific notions of beauty
for the development of theories of
everything uh grant unification and so
on and they
they did not work and they continue to
not work
so maybe i should clarify though that um
my problem is not
generally with using arguments from
beauty because um
i i'm very much with fire um
with firearms whatever works work works
okay so if beauty works for you that's
fine with me
the problem with these arguments from
beauty is that you have so many people
all
using the same very narrow ideas
of beauty that have become pretty much
dogmatic
in the community and then people do not
get the message the feedback from nature
that
these particular notions of beauty are
just not working
is that truly because in your book again
i'm going it's a classic book the
trouble with physics
2006 you talk about all these dead
theories
that were beautiful and you even hint
that maybe super symmetry won't be the
the saving grace but can you never
i never thought super symmetry was that
beautiful um
i think it's it's one thing at the
nature of advice that
scientists tell each other and it's
another thing to try to make a working
principle and
make a doctrine of it so i agree
partly with with either of you i mean
my phd defense stephen weinberg
afterwards took
pulled me aside and in
very appropriate for that moment
um tone he said can i give you some
advice
and i said sure and he said i'm going to
pass on to you the same advice that my
phd advisor gave me
at my phd and i said sure and he said
that advice is every once in a while
think a little bit about the weak
interactions
and then he smiled and he said that
really worked for me
and and i think that
scientists do pass down advice like that
and one of the pieces of advice is look
for something
which is beautiful so a few times
just speaking personally a few times in
my life
i've come upon something a calculation
or an idea
or a framework and
had the emotional experience of wow
that's really beautiful
which came along with that's really new
i've never seen that before and it has a
wonderful coherence the way that the
parts
fit together and i think that that's
part of the experience of doing the
science but i never put
in a paper doubly special relativity is
true
because it's it's especially beautiful
the way the parts fit together
and in fact sabina was the person who
demolished the theory not on the basis
of it not being beautiful but
not having a good local structure that
we expect theories to have with quantum
field theory
and so i think it's a matter of what you
take it
there is this experience a personal
experience of
coherence and simplicity and that's
those are good things but i i don't
think there
they should be properties that you hold
up in an argument about whether
something is true or whether there's
evidence for it
yeah i think this is a fantastic point
um
actually one of our youtube commenters i
think sort of summarized this uh drawing
eight
uh clarifying that beauty in physics is
symmetry plus simplicity
uh you know i think it actually would
behoove us to maybe
uh define what we mean by beauty but i
think
certainly there's a sense that really
beauty is you know
rather than a rule it's a it's a razor
the razor of beauty in the same family
as occam's razor
and bass and this is based on a real
observation that complex systems like
our universe tend to emerge from
simple laws you know it's true
essentially all the way up
and it just turns out that mathematical
elegance
often means fewer moving parts within
your mechanics for the universe so it's
not that a useful guiding principle
i think that's right i think that what
what the problem is
we say the word beauty as it's shorthand
for something
and it has to do with uh an economy
so richard dawkins said that the power
of the theory is what it explains
divided by what it assumes
and so beautiful theories tend to assume
almost nothing and give you almost
everything
and so effectively a theory of
everything more or less has to be
beautiful because it is the idea that
you're going to have a
self-bootstrapping
of all of the baroque complexity that we
see in our world of three generations 16
particles in a generation various
interactions of various strengths
to try to imagine that this comes from a
a source it it makes more sense that
this will hang together and this is also
we know post let's say uh investigations
of the 1980s in geometric quantum field
theory
is that we understand now that quantum
field theory would have been discovered
by mathematicians
studying borders theories if there were
no particles at all
it is a well-defined geometric
topological framework if you will
and as a result we know that effectively
things are held together much
better if they are geometrically
motivated just in the way
lee was talking before about background
independence once you learn to think in
a particular way you don't have to
continually check to see that you're not
coming up with nonsense like pseudo
tensors
but let me just give a warning we uh
aside from the technical difficulties
we're going to spend almost the entire
time talking about things that don't
work
things that have been thoroughly
explored whether it's loop quantum
gravity or string
theory or grand unification and
the most important thing if you really
want to talk about this is an active
subject as opposed to
a sort of historical subject is that you
have to say okay well
why is it that we can't escape the
gravitational pull
of the past failures why are we still
talking
about all of these same things that we
know not to bear fruit
that have been thoroughly investigated
this is sabina's point about
their idiosyncratic programs versus
large programs the large programs have
the benefit of having been explored by
large numbers of competent people
and so we more thoroughly know that
nothing is likely to come out no offense
to lee of
string theory loop quantum gravity
because
we've actually explored them a fair
amount to know that they don't yield up
the sort of fruits that people were
expecting whether it's the
astrocar variables or in the case of
quantum gravity or the anomaly
cancellation in the case of string
theory
but what's fascinating is that we're not
actually interested in processing our
own failures and then saying
and now what well i wonder sometimes if
we could cut up in that fallacy of the
appeal of the popular opinion
um you know that's not the way that
science works nor does the
fallacy of authority work either my
provocative quote is that the scientific
method is the radio edit of great
science
but lee you've even gone further and
said things such as maybe there isn't a
sign like a scientific method
can you elaborate i know you only have a
few minutes but it's very precious that
i'd like to understand
this provocative statement from you
about the scientific method and whether
or not
yeah let me say something very specific
um which which is a pointer most of my
thinking about the scientific method
is framed by paul fyrabin
that sabina mentioned and
fire robin's against method
but i've tried to go paul fire
i i think he has correctly characterized
many of the issues but i don't and he's
raised the question how is it that
science works
if there's not a method in the
old-fashioned
positivist way but he didn't answer that
problem
and i don't know if if it succeeded or
not
but the contribution that i've made to
try to answer that problem
is chapter 17 of the trouble with
physics and let me just refer people to
that
it's an approach which is not completely
original with me
the main idea of the approach is that
the science has to be explained
as the product of the community
and there are ethical principles which
guide how the community functions always
imperfectly
and always recognizing that there's
cheaters and people pushing the
boundaries
in the community and i try to
characterize
what it is about this community that
leads from time to time
to consensus after there's been
disagreement
in terms of arguing from the evidence so
um and the kind of
theme of that philosophy
or that description of what
what science is it starts by saying that
human beings are fallible
and we easily fool each other and we
easily fool ourselves
and science and the scientific community
is this collective set of
functions and tools
which when used properly
are good at finding error and i think
brian you'll agree
you're an experimental cosmologist and
probably 99.9
of what you do is seek to find errors
and eliminate them
that's right and that's what we
theorists do when we're doing our job as
well
yeah and sabina i don't think you would
disagree you talk about this as
in your advice that you gave in an
interview that we did advice to a young
physicist to look for the
inconsistencies
to use that as a guide um i wonder you
and
you know for for someone who is not
known for uh effervescent um
optimism and sanguinity on the state of
physics
um you do write recently that you know
you say something to the effect that
there's no need for quantum
gravity to explain any current
observation
but hopefully in this word hopefully
struck me in your language
um hopefully this will change in the
coming decades on what basis do you have
to hope
for such a thing to happen
well so there's a long-standing myth
that is very common in the
physics community that you cannot
possibly test quantum gravity
ever in our lifetime not in the next
million years and so on because
uh and i i believe this briefly came up
last week
um you need to build this collider
that's the size of the milky way
and uh it's not going to happen because
we have to face economic reality
um and there are lots of variants on
on that idea that you need to have an
unrealistically big machine
to ever test quantum gravity may that be
this big collider or you have to build a
graviton detector the size of the planet
jupiter
and put it in orbit around the neutron
stars
stuff like this so you can make a lot of
fun um
estimates uh on that account
but this fails to neglect that a
particular
specific property of gravity is that the
interaction becomes
stronger with larger masses so strictly
speaking when we say that we can't test
quantum gravity what we're actually
saying is
either the masses are so large that we
can measure the gravitational
field but then they don't have quantum
properties
or we have objects that have pronounced
quantum properties but then they also
like that we can't measure the
gravitational field
so so that's this that's the problem
that we have another thing is that
there has been a lot of technological
progress
in bringing heavier and heavier objects
into quantum superpositions
which offers the possibility that at
some point you may just be able to
measure the gravitational field and then
we can figure out
what's with the quantum properties of
gravity
and there's still several orders of
magnitude um
that uh people have to bridge uh in in
the experimental community
but we're not talking about 40 orders of
magnitude we're talking about something
like five to six orders of magnitude and
that's
in an area where there is a huge amount
of progress
lee if you do have to head out uh
perhaps you can
maybe say something at the end of the
last session i asked everyone to
give the impression of really what what
is the end game going
to look like you know what is it is it
that we need
to find a better question or uh you know
do we have any hope of actually asking
these fundamentally philosophical
questions about
no i think i said at the beginning what
i think the question is which is what is
the dynamical mechanism by which laws
evolve
and that's much more important than
under that is the explanation for what
the laws are
and it's not it's not a beautiful
symmetry
it must be a beautiful mechanism
something analogous to natural selection
and the other thing which i'm
which i personally think is likely
is that a common resolution of the
problems in quantum gravity and quantum
foundations
will involve the idea of locality and
what will happen to the idea of locality
is that space will turn out
to be an emergent structure and
therefore
fundamentally what's local and what's
not local
is dynamically determined and imagined
and that will be the source of the
resolution that's
my best and i'm happy to work in a
scientific community
where i have the privilege and i have to
say it is a privilege
to work on these questions and
i agree very strongly with sabrina
and eric who in different ways are
pointing to the problem of the diversity
of
people and ideas in the field especially
a physic
thank you so much uh for uh well your
insights
um and and your profound uh
parting words also is this stuff that we
all need to think a lot more about
thank you this has been thank you
sabine and eric can address those
questions as well i can't resist because
the people in the
in the comment section are wondering
sabina um
about your perspective and eric your
perspective
um you know this is not a rumble they're
they're not here to defend themselves
wait a minute i was told that this would
be a rumble otherwise it wouldn't
say i said you know yeah i said i said
let's get ready t-o-e
rumble uh but uh we're not gonna rumble
uh sabine would kick your butt anyway
but the but the point is um what do you
guys think about the
what's in the air why are there so many
new theories of everything
uh eric why why do you think what
inspire i mean yours theory dates back
to 2013 perhaps but
stephen wolfram's garrett 1983
or something like that what do you make
of wolfram's theory and what do you make
of this
critique that i get from sabine
sometimes you know basically
i i i don't have time because we all
have limited time
uh but uh but i know enough not to
you know feel like it's it's worth
devoting a lot of attention to these i
mean
that being said you did go to hawaii to
meet with garrett uh sadina so
first eric what's your take uh and not
you know be charitable because he's not
here
but on the approach of wolfram or or
would you take it seriously and if not
why not
well first of all i take every
independent researcher trying a theory
of everything who's
trying not to fool him or herself i'm
supportive of that
because there's almost nobody who fits
that description unfortunately
as to why this is happening and you know
again i i i'm just a little bit
concerned that we have this thing called
theories of everything we're not really
talking about theories of everything
it's the first opportunity
let's be more honest than we'd like to
be uh in general
um because mommy and daddy have failed
the kids are misbehaving so the idea
that you know stephen wolfram was just
talking to me and he said i really
thought i was going to run into all the
same resistance that i had before i
didn't realize that the community
wasn't in a position to offer it anymore
so having effectively
lied and failed uh to say what it was
doing and where we were
and how things were progressing there's
a huge credibility gap with all the
people who are supposed to be tamping
this down
so we have to be honest that in general
my guess is that lisa would have been
the one person in this community who
would
still be you know viewed at some level
by the core community as kind of on
board with the core
sabine is of course a rebel talking she
has about
string theory lee in his trouble with
physics same thing
the core community is not able to
suppress this stuff as much as it used
to
because it is not in fact credible and
that is a large met
uh reason for why it's possible
to roam around and to you know say
things on the internet now
i'm in a very interesting situation
where i have almost a quarter
sorry i have almost half a million views
on the youtube for geometric unity
on that lecture and yet uh
there really hasn't been a substantive
discussion of what's in it what it's
about or anything
we just always talk around physics now
and so i think it's really important to
recognize that we don't actually
do physics much what we do is
if somebody told you that there was an
attack
by a joint russian chinese force
on western science right science in
western europe the americas and japan
let's say
and that it was going to work by getting
everyone to talk about popper
everyone to talk about string theory
about
the scientific method about uh fire
albin we can't even pronounce his name
or spell it
uh all of these things is we talk around
what it is that we're supposed to be
doing we don't actually do it we don't
talk about
muons um and it's fascinating to me that
we're talking about theories of
everything
or as if it's like some sort of like
there are none
that have been accepted and
the issue of who is claiming one stephen
wolfram is of claiming to have a theory
of everything
garrett lisey is not claiming to have a
theory of everything
these are people who have some sort of a
program
and we have an idea of why wolfram
believes that his rules
generate complexity that wasn't present
obviously in the rule so particularly
generative rules
in a computer science cellular atom
perspective are incredibly generative so
his claim is i
it looks like these could generate
differential geometry and therefore the
underpinnings of the standard model in
gr
in garrett's case he had an original
hope which is
okay there's uh 16 particles in a
generation has to do with spinner groups
there are weird ways in which spinners
and what would be called the adjoint
representation can be fit together
um in in what are known as exceptional
e-groups i bet the largest one contains
a three-fold symmetry called triality
which gives you the three generations of
matter
now that didn't work and it didn't work
for reasons uh i told
garrett at a conference organized by
sabine at perimeter where lee is of
bringing it all back together
and that didn't work now garrett is sort
of on to something else but he won't
exactly admit that the old program
didn't work
even though um you know he based it on
triality of e8 which is a non-trivial
observation since it's not manifest
so you know those are noble attempts to
do
something but they're not theories of
everything and
we're not honest or clear i think that
there would be a breakout of theories of
everything if anyone had one but it's
almost impossible to fool yourself into
thinking you have one because the
constraints are too great
and you know it happens to be that maybe
because i'm not a physicist i can fool
myself into thinking i have one um but
i just don't believe that theories of
everything have broken out what has
happened is
that people have become bold because
kumran
and ed and and david aren't going to
shut everyone down
and if you know who those names
correspond to then you know exactly why
it was that a lot of dissent was
suppressed
subpoena do you have a rubric do you
have a checklist you know that you say
a theory has to pass before i will
invest you know use my time
to investigate it further well
first maybe let me make a comment about
what
eric just said you complained that there
has not been any substantive
discussion about geometric unity i think
that's because no one has any idea what
you're talking about in the first place
i think you're severely underestimating
the communication problem
and you have to work much much harder on
that and yeah i i watched your lecture
and you know i think that among the
half a million people who watched uh
your video i'm probably one of those
uh who have a pretty good starting point
uh in understanding what you're even
talking about
and even i only have a very weak idea uh
what you're even up to
and so let me then come to your question
about why we're seeing this
uh renaissance of theories of everything
i think that's partly
um what we're seeing is uh people coming
of age who've grown up with this idea
that there has to be a theory of
everything
it's just a sociological aspect you know
people
um who went into physics in in the 80s
um maybe late 70s early 80s something
like this
they were all told there has to be the
theory of everything and it's the next
logical step after the development of
the standard model and before you know
we'll have found it it's just that it
didn't happen
and so then we've seen like 20 30 years
people going on about how great string
theory is and that
in the end didn't pan out okay and now
you you have these people who've been
silently working on their theory of
everything
you know in secret on their desk and
nobody wanted to listen to them because
everyone's been talking about string
theory
who um probably now are encouraged to
finally give it the final push
out uh and i suspect that we will
probably see
some more uh of that and i think it
that that's a good development even
though as i said i'm not
terribly excited about people trying to
solve non-problems
uh nevertheless you never know what uh
what they will stumble upon yeah
personally
if i can finish this i'm almost done
what i find
more exciting um is that
we're seeing much more interest now in
the foundations of quantum mechanics
um which has uh you know there's not a
lot that
has happened uh for you know
half a century uh or something and it's
now again it's mostly driven by
technological development
um that they're more things that people
can test and now there's this revival
of interest in the foundations of
quantum mechanics and this has come up a
few times in the discussion here i think
that
the uh solution to um uh
the question what do you do about
quantum gravity
will ultimately come from a better
understanding of
uh quantization and uh locality in
quantum mechanics so we have i i
definitely want to give eric a chance to
respond but it sounds like to paraphrase
you know max planck
it might be yeah let me wait for a few
more funerals
uh uh for physics to progress uh matt
you're gonna take something but i think
we should give eric a chance to respond
to that body blow
landed in the ninth round uh yeah and
not just a chance to respond but also
maybe a chance to tell
the audience when when we might see more
about geometric unity when when should
we should we be monitoring
all right so first of all samina i i
thought you were going to say
something like this this is preposterous
by the way
i think the world of sabina uh her
integrity and her curmudgeonly
nature uh have been a huge boon to
physics so keep doing what you're doing
and there would be no there's no one i'd
rather fight with given that the gloves
are off
sabina that's not true look assume that
you had
a space-time manifold right and normally
we need a four dimensions
four dimensions for that before you have
a metric here's a one-dimensional
manifold in the form of a circle
okay now it happens that you have to
create in geometric unity
an ambient space which would be a fiber
bundle okay
that would look like in the case of a
circle
uh a disconnected object which we will
call y
call the hair tie x which is that band
around the core
and this is y which is the space of
metrics
these would be time-like these would be
space-like metrics right
so the idea is that a an einsteinian
space time is a wrapping
if you will of a hair tie around the
core
and the idea is that the physics is
taking place both on
the hair tie and on the pour all right
and so if the space time metric is down
here you're going to pull back different
information
uh at the bottom of this core than if it
were at the top that's just saying it's
a section of the bundle of metrics
that's
straight up einstein right
what i am saying is is that the bundle
of metrics
this object y has a funny feature which
is
that it has a metric on it almost
so i'm going to put a toothpick right
now through the core
of the roll representing what i would
call the horizontal
tangent space which is not pointed along
the tube if it was pointed along the
tube then
the y structure would have a metric and
then it could have things like electrons
and
muons and neutrinos and the like but in
fact it points off
so one of the issues of geometric unity
is pushing
this horizontal subspace along the tube
to be a perpendicular
to the vertical subspace therefore the
space of metrics that einstein gave us
actually weirdly almost inherits a
metric without any choices of a metric
on the original space
on that you define all of your particles
and the 10 dimensions that einstein
gives us of the
non of the coupled partial differential
equations are the same
10 as the spin 10 unified theory
okay so the idea is you have a
coincidence you learned about something
involving 10 in the case of einstein's
general relativity you also have
10 cropping up in grand unified theory
10 is 2 times 5 for the su5 theory
if you think about something called the
petit salaam theory
that's usually given as su4 cross su 2
press su 2 it should be called spin 6
cross spin 4 6 plus 4 is 10. 10 is
coming up over and over and over again
it's also
d squared plus d divided by two if d
equals four
right all of these things give you a
structure where there is no internal
symmetry groups
and that was the huge problem with
supersymmetries is that you never got
rid of the
double origin story you had a space-time
origin story
and then you had a fiber origin story
where out of the blue
or in yiddish coming from nowhere
you put su 3 cross su 2 cross u1
which because you never pulled that out
of anything organic and geometric
the idea is that when you did super
symmetry on top of it by the way which
is not a symmetry i don't know why we
insist on calling it that
um you were working on the wrong group
the idea is that where
you saw the lorentz group is where you
should use the gauge group now sabina
what you call the gauge group is
actually
technically called the structure group
so you i'm not talking about the
finite dimensional objects that you were
talking about before
but you should form the infinite
dimensional gauge group and just as you
form the inhomogeneous extension of the
in-home
of the lorentz group to form the poncare
group you should form the inhomogeneous
extension of the gauge group which is an
infinite dimensional gadget do super
symmetry on that
remove the internal symmetries and
generate them
by the virtue of the fact that the
proto-space-time before it inhabits
the province of romanian or semi-ramani
in geometry
you should look at the bundle of metrics
realize that that almost has a metric on
it therefore it effectively almost has
spinners on it and
closing out this little riff on
geometric unity
one of the problems that people keep
talking about oh we can't quantize
gravity
you have a bigger problem than that
which is that the electron
and the quarks and the neutrinos and all
these particles
that are mapped that are matter depend
on a
particular choice of a metric they don't
exist in the absence of one
so you have in the case of a photon you
have
the c in which the photon is a wave if
you will and then you have the wave
itself
and you can say well i don't know where
the wave is between observation
if you don't know where the metric is
then you don't know where the ocean is
between observations and the difference
between
being at the beach and not being exactly
sure where the waves are
versus being at the beach and not being
sure where the pacific ocean is
is an entirely different world of pain
and for whatever reason the physicists
are not
particularly bothered by this so one of
the things that geometric unity does
is it takes the issue of the fact that
the electron bundle
the medium in which the electron is a
wave doesn't exist between observations
of the metric
and it says we're going to solve that
for you by working over the space of all
metrics showing that that has
an almost metric coming from the fact
that it has a chimeric bundle
which is partially along the space and
partially pointing away from the space
geometric unity tamps that down and that
means that electrons are defined between
observations of the gravitational metric
which could be up here or down here
because the entire space of metrics
effectively has a metric
so i don't have to let's give sabine a
chance to respond
yeah let's take one more minute all
right
sabina you said this thing about like th
this doesn't solve
uh problems of physics [ __ ] i mean
you don't know why they're three
generations i'm telling you they're two
generations plus an imposter generation
you don't know why the world is chiral
i'm claiming it isn't chiral
i'm claiming that it has two chiral
halves that decoupled with an illusion
of emergent chirality rather than
fundamental chirality
there are all sorts of things that i'm
trying to show you i'm trying to show
you
the fact that there are two lagrangians
not one in that the dirac equation and
the einstein equations
belong to the first order of lagrangian
and that the
yang mills lagrangian in equations
and the higgs or klein gordon with
potential
belong to the second order lagrange so i
don't think that it's the case that this
has nothing to contribute you may be
very busy
but i don't think that that is the
problem of geometric unity i could
certainly explain this
to you you know in terms that are
familiar manifold theory
sabine so i i kind of have the
impression we're talking a little bit
past each other
um because you just said let's let's
just pick this
uh you're telling me why there are three
generations
and that supposedly solves the problem
but i i don't see that there is any
problem with just having three
generations that's that's
the whole point that i've tried to get
across it's there's nothing inconsistent
with the standard model the way that it
is there's no problem to solve
it's the same thing with chirality so
the standard model is cairo
what's the problem with that the one
problem that we really have
the one problem that we really have is
the missing quantization
of gravity and so on that count i would
say well if you claim that you have
successfully quantized gravity then uh
please tell me what's the gravitational
field of light electron in a
superposition can you do the calculation
can you show that your theory
is uv finite which by the way
um string theories still have shown at
least um
not in our actual universe so that's
still an unsolved open
problem and also i i regret to say but
if you don't understand what people find
hard
to grasp about your ideas maybe you
should get a little
bit more feedback about just exactly why
it's incomprehensible
well in the case of so you just said
something that's slightly
incomprehensible to me
which is for example uh let's take your
chirality point
um what makes the decision about left
versus right-handedness
i mean in other words if the universe
has a beauty mark
in the in the sense that let's say
marilyn monroe or cindy crawford had a
famous beauty mark
what chose the asymmetry to to break
left or to the right
positive or negative
that's not a problem no that's not a
problem why is that a problem
you know we have we have a theory that
works that's fine with me i'm afraid i'm
an instrumentalist
i see but surely this has been about
getting to
the the fundamental question what is our
theory supposed to do is it merely
supposed to describe the universe
or is it supposed to be deeply
explanatory
of some of these philosophical questions
about a teacher
why is the universe
you know i i just think that
fundamentally that's a question which is
not in the realm of
science you know the best thing that we
can do is uh we could say well we have a
lot of observations
what's the most economical theory that
we can write
uh down for this and this this has also
come up a few times
uh in in this discussion last week by
um uh max i think tech mark who brought
it up and eric also already said this a
good theory is one that explains a lot
from a little and so we can certainly
push to that
a little harder um you know and we can
always push
a little harder but in the end as as
einstein
said you can only make things as simple
as possible and not
any simpler and um
maybe the way that the standard model is
is just the simplest
as possible and the only thing that's
missing
sabine can you reconcile that with your
well-known stated position
opposition to things like the future
circular collider
uh that our guest last week james
beecham spoke spoke so highly of
where it's almost like it's not really a
choice between
doing the fcc and doing you know climate
modeling it's really the fcc
and at least in my particle physics
firms are telling me or nothing
and that's the future of particle
physics and aren't you cutting off
potentially
this uh this goal based on the fact that
you're saying
you know two different things you're
saying on one hand we have to get more
data
and we can use the data to refine the
models but what if you cut off
let me ask you this question simpler if
you were you know the
the queen of the planet uh more so than
now
but if you were and you had infinite
resources where would you be putting
those resources tell me theoretically
you know postdocs
uh experiments where would you put that
infinite amount of resources forget
about the other ways we could use the
opportunity cost
i would put my limited resources in an
educational program
that teaches all physicists that
resources are not unlimited
so we have to make decisions about where
to put our money
and the message that i have to try to to
get across
is that putting a lot of money into a
big
collider is not a good investment
you know they're better experiments that
we could do for
less money that have a larger expected
pail it's just currently not
a good way to invest our money and i i
have to say you know
maybe let let me add this that um
physicists
and i've i've been part of this
community for a long time
have basically made it a taboo to even
ask the question
how expensive is it is it worth it
they'll stand up and say oh let's not
talk about the money
and i'm like well what planet do you
live on you know the planet that i live
on money matters
so it's not really true that i mean we
do spend a lot of money on education
and i don't even mean you know to just i
know you're kind of being
tongue-in-cheek
but um but what about the post-docs i
mean i've heard i've had people say
eric you know we have too many post-docs
we you know we the field can't afford it
i mean i personally
don't have enough as an experimentalist
it's hard to find but um
where would you spend resources um part
b and part a
anything that you wanted to respond to
that you haven't had a chance to do that
well sure i mean the first thing is i'm
not a physicist
let me be very clear about that second
of all um i have a very difficult time
with the physics
third of all you guys need vastly more
money
and as much as i'm disappointed in you
and as much as i'm pissed off and angry
about the way in which the community has
fallen into a state of what i would
consider to be disrepair
the key thing is is that there's
something painful about watching the
community that
birthed the world wide web the
devices that we use to communicate with
each other both through the
semiconductors
and through electromagnetic spectrum
all of the wonders of theoretical
physics more or less powered the entire
world
and in terms of the economy what ended
wars what have you
it is obscene that the theoretical
physics community
and its pro and its experimental uh
allies
have to ask for billions of dollars like
a beggar with a bowl in hand
when you actually provided the universe
with
most of what we take for granted as
powering the modern world
and you guys sign the world's worst
licensing arrangement ever
so the first thing i would do is to put
money into renegotiating your deal with
the universe because these are not
taxpayer dollars they are physics
dollars that we allow the taxpayers
to make use of in large measure you can
reframe this
and the fact that you guys are actually
not talking about pushing out the budget
constraint is obscene we saw this in
public health
where people were talking about how
should we spend the pittance that
has been given for tropical disease and
the economist in the
u.s had a brilliant idea which is why
are we talking about a pittance let's
push the budget constraint way the hell
out
so the first thing is is that where we
are is pathetic
we should give you guys a collider even
though it's unlikely to work
and we should stop carping about a few
billion dollars it's pathetic it's
preposterous it's ridiculous
so i think that that's the first frame
of mind which is i refuse to work
in a pauper's framework given our
military spending you guys are see
seal team six for the human mind um we
should keep our physicists fat happy
and fighting with each other rather than
mathematicians online i appreciate them
and what i would say uh in terms of what
sabine is
saying is look i don't think that this
stuff is all that confusing
i think that you know in fact the key
idea is that we're not that jazzed
about theories of everything we want to
talk around theories of everything we
want to talk to sociology we want to
talk about economics we want to talk
about history
we talk everything other than actually
saying
hey does anybody have any new ideas and
this is
really funny because in effect there's
no reason for preceding funeral by
funeral
it's it's preposterous everybody's out
of ideas i mean
if you were a prominent person and you
had major ideas we'd know
and the key issue is why are we not
doing something that is more
vital and the answer is is that
at some level you know sabine is playing
a
very important role the curmudgeon the
skeptic the person who
you know says show me uh i think that
that's really important i think that
there's a cautionary tale
which doesn't we don't understand well
enough involving rosalind franklin and
watson and crick and charga and the idea
is that both
watson and crick were irresponsible they
just were
they were irresponsible as scientists
and chargaff
who thought that they knew nothing about
biochemistry and uh
rosalind franklin who thought that they
didn't have enough reason to think it
should be a helix that they were just
copying linus pauling's alpha
helix from protein all these people got
it wrong
and the irresponsible people got it
right and
the issue of encouraging
more people to be somewhat irresponsible
and hopefully pay back whatever they've
stolen from the intellectual till by the
end of the day
is far better than this thing like what
lee was saying before
about good science i'm so bored of
oatmeal
you know i don't want to eat my fiber
anymore i don't want more asparagus
at some point you just want to have a
big slice of like warm apple pie
with ice carrick uh we're gonna have to
wrap up
these are inspiring fighting words um
but uh before we close i do want to get
one last piece of inspiration from both
of you
besides thinking more about the weak
nuclear force
what advice would you give to a young
aspiring physicist uh
sabine well i've already said this right
i think that it's very exciting that
there is a renewed interest in the
foundations of uh
quantum mechanics and
uh i think basically that the future is
there so um
[Music]
you know look at that what about you
eric
uh i would say look at the fact
that um nobody asked the question about
why
10 and spin 10 grand unified theory i
would say
um if the universe had
a new particles how do you know that
these are three generations if you don't
know that they wouldn't unify with those
new particles differently if you up the
energy scale
i would say to you um why is it that
everybody talks about
complaints about locality nobody talks
about the tia patodi singer index
theorem with its non
local ada term that crops up out of
nowhere
i would say that people don't
investigate
the issue of what supersymmetry actually
is
if it is not a symmetry why is it that
we accept two origin stories just
the way uh you would in the old
testament with lilith and british
when you have one for the substrate that
is the einstein space-time manifold and
another for the su-3 plus su-2 plus you
want internal
and auxiliary symmetry groups make sure
that you have one
origin story before you start trying to
apply supersymmetry
i would say any one of a huge number of
things but the key
overarching thing is that the field has
mis-explained itself
through the same leaders repeating and
reciting the exact same things
over and over again go back to a period
before
1984. looking at a book called shelter
island 2
when just before string theory's anomaly
cancellation happened and look at murray
gelman's opening remarks
if you have to come up with an
understanding of what the field was
before the madness took over look at
geometric quantization
look at geometric quantum field theory
and understand that we have two
different geometries one built on
charles erismont theory one
built on bernard green month underlying
the two halves
stop talking about this in the same
terms that edwin and david gross
taught you to speak about all of these
things and instead find a new way of
formulating because there are millions
and most people
are acting as if they're stepford wives
repeating the same thing stop worrying
about money
get somebody to raise funds for you
speaking of raising funds uh we'd be
remiss
if we didn't mention sabine's wonderful
book
lost in math which is available in
paperback and hardcover
eric you have the portal wiki uh and
also the portal podcast
matt do you have any concluding remarks
my concluding remark would be to
look at brian's excellent book uh losing
the nobel prize
uh and you should also definitely head
to his podcast
uh into the impossible uh where you'll
actually hear conversations
with these two geniuses and plenty of
other people it's
extremely enlightening it's been an
absolute pleasure and
brian and matt thank you guys for having
us thank you all thanks for this uh
rather unusual episode of a mildly
chaotic
space time